he's one of the greatest stand-up
comedians of all time and when he gave
that up he became a massive movie star
not to mention one of the most popular
Saturday Night Live hosts ever yet in
recent years
Steve Martin has all but disappeared
from both the big screen and the small
so what's he been up to instead he has a
look at the real reason we don't hear
from Steve Martin anymore busy with
bluegrass banjo playing once played a
major role in Martin's stand-up routines
but his banjo skills are actually no
joke in the late 2000s Martin reinvented
himself as a serious musician how
serious not only has he had a number one
hit single and performed at the Grand
Ole Opry several times he even when a
Grammy for the song love has come for
you with musical partner Eddie Pakal
[Music]
Martin thinks there's something
mysterious and uniquely American about
the banjo telling NPR there's something
very compelling about it to certain
people I'd like to think it's because
we're Americans and the banjo is truly
an American instrument and it captures
something about our past the right stuff
considering Martin wrote the scripts for
several hit films including Roxane
Bowfinger
and la story it's not really a surprise
that he's been just as successful in the
publishing business as he has been in
the movie business in 2000 his novella
shop girl was a top 10 New York Times
best seller for 15 weeks and he later
followed that up with the novel's the
pleasure of my company and an object of
beauty his most successful book though
isn't fiction but rather his 2007 memoir
born standing up a comics life which
chronicles has rise to the top of the
stand up world before abruptly quitting
forever in 1981 Martin told NPR he sees
the book as less about comedy and more
about the journey of a self-made man
I think it's somehow an American story
because I started untalented I didn't
have any gifts except perseverance the
Great White Way given Steve Martin's
fondness for both music and writing it
makes sense that the star would
eventually satisfied from Broadway in
2014
Martin and Raquel wrote and produced
bright sir a musical drama inspired by
the duo's album love has come for you
the play made his way to Broadway in
2016 where it racked up five Tony
nominations including Best Musical best
book in a Musical and Best Score but
lost to the cultural juggernaut known as
Hamilton but bright star wasn't Martin's
first foray into playwriting in 1993
Martin penned forecaster at the LA
Panaji eel which depicts a conversation
between public acaso and Albert Einstein
the play made international headlines in
2009 when outraged parents objected to
the character's questionable behavior
and successfully prevented students at
Oregon's Legrand High School from
mounting a production
Martin was funded by offering to fund an
off-campus production of Picasso and
pens a scathing editorial in La Grande
observer in which he argued that despite
the plays adult content the spirits of
the play and his endorsement of the Arts
and Sciences are appropriate for young
guys in
family man Steve Martin tends to keep
his private life to himself in 2007 he
invited his closest friends over for a
dinner party which turned out to be a
surprise wedding in 2012 when the actor
was 67 years old Martin's wife former
New York Times FAFSA and Stringfield
gave birth to the comedian's first child
and nobody knew about it for months in
fact the public still doesn't even know
what her name is something Martin has
made light of an interviews I thought
about the name quite a bit concrete
stood or what do you think being a dad
have changed Martin's priorities he told
The Telegraph when I was younger I was
selfish and focused on my career now I'm
just hanging around the house playing
with my daughter it's great hi art ever
since he bought his first print in 1968
Martin has been an avid art collector
with a collection that includes
everything from multiple Picasso's for
the grungy alternative cartoons of
American comic book artist Robert Crumb
and the first thing I bought happened to
be an Ed Roush a print of Hollywood
Hollywood sign while Martin usually
keeps the details of his personal
collection characteristically private
the comedian used his fame to bring
attention to a little-known Canadian
artist named Lauren Harris by organizing
an exhibition that appeared in Los
Angeles Boston and Toronto of course for
Martin are collecting isn't all fun and
games
in 2004 he fourth landscape of horses by
Dutch painter Heinrich camp and dunk for
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
only to learn later that the piece was
one of 44 forgeries produced by a group
of German criminals even then Martin was
able to take it all in stride
sets down comedy in February 2016 Steve
Martin took the stage in New York's
Beacon Theater and delivered a 10-minute
stand-up set his first in 35 years it
was a favor to headliner Jerry Seinfeld
after an appearance on Seinfeld
comedians and cars getting coffee where
Martin explains why he suddenly quit
stands up at the top of his game in 1981
part of my goal was to be absurd
in a very serious time I could tell that
the era was ending to even feel it
old man Martin let's face it even for a
younger man building a movie can be a
grueling experience despite Hollywood's
glamorous image actors often work
extremely long hours get very little
sleep and don't always get days off
often spending weeks away from home
Martin told biography now that he's in
his 70s and have a family but that stuff
doesn't sound so appealing anymore it's
difficult the process of making a movie
if a studio had its way that have you
working 14 hours a day every day as you
get older your life actually becomes
more important than your career believe
it or not he could make a comeback
Martin may be spending his time out of
the spotlight now but he's still one of
the most respected names in Hollywood
both for his comedic and dramatic acting
skills there's no question he could make
a comeback if he wanted to but between
his music his plays his novels and his
family right now it doesn't seem like
making movies is a priority for him so
which there's really only one
appropriate response well thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea
[Music]